[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of fandango indie
movie Guide and I've got plenty of
recommendations for you this week so I'm
just gonna get right into it
with my pick of the week called a
fantastic woman this is a Chilean drama
directed by Sebastian Lili oh it tells
the story of a trans woman who is
dealing with the grief of losing her
lover her boyfriend and to add salt to
her wounds she's getting a lot of
attitude and injustice from his family
from the police and even from the
doctors at the hospital we looked in the
machine of infinite an animal
the performance at the center of this
movie daniela vega is so strong she
plays her character with this real sense
of hardened strength she wants to grieve
her boyfriend she's not even able to do
that in the usual way
it's a powerhouse performance a
fascinating story we'll keep you engaged
throughout and gives you a tiny tiny
little window into the kind of everyday
hate that trans people have to face I
definitely recommend seeing a fantastic
woman available in limited theaters this
weekend another pick you have to see if
you can is called mud bound it's
directed by Dean Reese and it stars
Carey Mulligan Garrett Hedlund Jason
Mitchell mary j blige and Jason Clarke
it's set during World War Two in the
American South and it's about two
families a white family and African
American family living on the same land
it's all about racism at this time and
class struggles I don't know what they
let you do over there but you had
Mississippi now you use the back door
and I have to say the cinematography is
amazing Rachel Morrison remember her
name because she is a cinematographer
who has been pumping out excellent work
in many many many Indies each frame
looks like a photograph and there's that
feeling of sticky mud throughout the
whole of the movie definitely check out
my bound it is well worth your time
incredible performances all around as
well
when I think of the farm I think of mud
I dreamed and brown and too quick
recommendations the first is mr.
Roosevelt a comedy directed by Noel
wells she also stars in the film as a
struggling comedian who returns to her
home town of Austin where she feels the
same but everything else is different
and she has to question whether her
struggles are worth it for her dreams or
if she would be happier at home and
other people around her much happier
than she is so after you staying with
your ex-boyfriend his new girlfriend did
I make yes she is super super nice and
put together and everything in her life
is beautiful and nothing's out of place
it focuses on a lot of things that you
question throughout your 20s and into
your 30s as well very funny and sweet
check out mr. Roosevelt it's available
in limited theaters from this weekend
one two three say mr. Roosevelt maybe
you've had too much to drink and last
but not least a great documentary called
big Sonya this is about a 91 year old
Holocaust survivor who has been running
a tailor shop for more than 30 years she
is a character in herself she loves
wearing colors she is larger-than-life
personality she has a great demeanor
about her but when her shop is served an
eviction notice she's forced to face her
horrifying past but in doing that she
actually ends up changing lives
she's the only Holocaust survivor
speaking publicly in Kansas City and her
story is remarkable shocking emotional
and really inspiring at the same time
teenagers are really hard
if I reach one harm I accomplish
something
she made me want to change things the
way things are she made me want to make
an impact who it gave me chills make
sure you see big Sonya if you can it's
available in theaters from this weekend
The Tortoise music differently when I
hear and I see denying that never
happened and the hate is still growing
speaking up is not enough they have it
for great recommendations for your
weekend if you can try to catch a
fantastic woman mud bound mr. Roosevelt
or big Sonya I'm Alicia Malone you can
always catch me Appalachian alone on
Twitter happy Thanksgiving everyone and
I'll see you next week
[Music]